Narrator:
These are the Sharks.
They have achieved
incredible success
as entrepreneurs and investors
in multiple sectors.
[ Crowd cheering ]
They all came
from humble beginnings,
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
[ Bell dinging ]
And tonight,
it's six Sharks in the Tank
for even more bite.
Your valuation is crazy.
You are here on a unique day
in "Shark Tank" history.
There are six Sharks.
Now you're talking.
We are pioneering
experiential learning.
I'm first and best.
Cuban: No, you're not.
What are your sales?
Probably about $2,000.
So you're losing money?
[ Sighs ]
That's entirely misplaced.
I've learned that
happiness can't buy money.
I have a big dream.
You guys got to learn to listen
more than you sell.
Narrator: This is
the art of doing business.
You have
a lot of competition.
This is "Shark Tank."
I'm calling you out.
No!
♪♪
I'm Meagan Bowman.
I'm from Ogden, Utah.
I live with my husband, Wes,
and our two beautiful daughters.
Entrepreneurship has always
been inside of me.
Ever since I was a little kid,
I was doing bake sales
and haunted houses
and any other way I could
raise money for myself.
Since childhood,
my life has been a little tough.
Finding a career path was tough,
and I fell back on welfare.
Being on welfare
was humiliating.
It was one of the first times
in my life
I haven't been able
to take care of myself.
I came up with my product idea
because I had a phone call
with my dad,
and he reminded me of an idea
that I had
when I was a teenager.
Man: So proud of you.
Bowman: Thanks, Dad.
You know you got this
entrepreneur side
from me, right?
[ Laughs ]
I've been watching "Shark Tank"
since season two,
and just watching
the other entrepreneurs
live out their dreams
pushed me to finally
take that plunge.
I started trying out
for "Shark Tank,"
and I failed each time.
And then something told me
to try one more time.
And I got the phone call
that I would get the opportunity
to pitch in front of the Sharks.
You're it.
This business means
so much to me
because it is one
of the first successful things
that I've done,
outside of having children.
And I just want it to be around
for a really long time for us.
♪♪
Hi.
My name is Meagan Bowman.
I'm from Ogden, Utah.
And I'm the founder
of a company called Eco Flower.
I'm here today
seeking $400,000
in exchange
for 10% of my company.
Let me share a little secret
with you.
Women are growing tired
of the gift‐bouquet cycle.
Get flowers,
watch them die,
procrastinate the trip
to the garbage,
and then wait for the day
when somebody gives her
another vase full
of plant carcasses.
[ Chuckles ]
There's a better way.
Introducing Eco Flower.
I found a floral solution
that provides my customers with
a beautiful bunch of flowers
that not only lasts forever,
but are also made with recycled
and sustainable materials.
We create with burlap,
jute twine, bamboo,
book pages, beer bottles,
wine bottles,
lots of other materials
that create timeless gifts,
stunning bridal bouquets,
and d‐decoration
for your home and businesses.
Sharks, together,
we'll captivate
the hearts of the women
who will start to love
getting flowers again.
And I got
each one of you gifts
that I wanted to hand out
before we start.
So, Robert...
‐Oh, wow.
‐Thank you very much.
[ Giggles ]
Wow. Fancy.
So, this is
"Croatia Loves Australia."
This would be Croatia
over here,
and this is Kim's
home country, Australia.
So,
if you guys didn't know...
Corcoran:
Oh, a wedding gift.
And this is a heart.
All: Aww.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Sniffle!
Lori, I got you
one of our bouquets.
Thank you.
‐This is beautiful.
‐Thank you.
Mr. Wonderful.
I was like, "Ugh, he has
the whole Something Wonderful
platform,"
and I wanted to show you
what I can do with weddings...
Okay.
... and so this is
a bridal bouquet,
and that's
a matching boutonniere.
‐Yeah?
‐Oh.
And all of your stuff
is scented.
So, yours is lemon,
that's black raspberry.
Oh, that smells
so nice.
Can I smell that?
Barbara, I got you a spring
bouquet with spring colors.
How lovely.
I love the springtime.
And then, Daymond, I got you
lapels for your jacket.
Cool.
All right.
And, Mr. Cuban...
Herjavec:
Those are lapels?
Yeah.
This has $140 in it,
and if I don't get
a deal today,
you got
to give it back,
'cause I'm a little
tight on cash.
[ Chuckling ]
Thank you so much.
Cool?
Look at that.
That's made
with real money.
‐Wow.
‐I'm spending it.
[ Laughter ]
John: I love these.
Do you individually make these,
Meagan?
I used to make them,
and it got out of my hands,
and so now we ‐‐
Well, that's a good sign.
Yeah. We have two manufacturers
that make them for us.
Herjavec: Meagan,
it's very pretty...
Thank you.
... but let me ask this question
to the ladies up here.
Lori, Barbara, if a man sent you
this instead of real flowers,
how would you feel
about that?
Oh, my.
You want
an honest answer?
O'Leary: Meagan,
I can answer that for you.
‐Yeah, honest answer.
‐Wait, wait.
It's the lack
of sensitivity.
That's
a good point.
I feel like I should feel
precious like a flower.
Lori,
what would you say?
I would rather have
a real flower.
Bowman: This is not true!
So, Lori would rather
have real flowers.
Barbara would rather have
real flowers.
What does
that say?
My customers have
a completely different story.
I don't know what women say when
you're in a wealthy community,
but in the community
I come from,
if a man buys you flowers,
spends $50 on it,
you're upset with him.
‐Wow.
‐Really?
Like, a lot of women are upset
that, like, that $50
could have gone
towards groceries...
Could I get that
in writing?
... or a lot of other things,
so...
Well, I don't know
about that.
When they can
keep it forever,
the women
cherish it more.
Well,
you can prove us wrong.
John: Here's how
Okay.
What are your sales?
Lifetime sales
are $2.8 million.
‐Wow.
Oh, wow, good for you.
I've only been open
for a year and a half.
Oh, good for you.
That's awesome.
‐Wow.
‐Whoa.
It's all
direct‐to‐consumer
through our website.
Nice.
What do you sell
your bundle for?
So, it's about $59
for a bridal bouquet.
That's really good.
Yeah.
‐That's very nice.
‐Really good.
How did it happen that
you started this business?
So, I saw an episode
of "Shark Tank,"
and I'm like,
"I wish I had an idea."
So I called my dad and he said,
"Remember the wood flowers
that you used to sell
when you were in high school?
This is an idea you could do
for 'Shark Tank.'"
And so,
I literally tried out
when I was only two weeks
into business.
Of course,
I didn't make it very far.
But, without "Shark Tank,"
I wouldn't have thought...
Awesome.
... on my past.
You have
a lot of competition.
I know.
I've seen them.
Nobody is selling them
in the masses by the bouquets.
They're for crafting.
People are getting them on Etsy,
like six at a time,
to put them in little hair bows
for their kids,
but nobody has a bouquet that
you can buy online for a gift.
What I can tell you is,
they're not used heavily
in the wedding industry
because people want
live flowers.
The industry
is set up...
Yeah.
I think, for sure.
...'cause you pass
a lot of contacts
and take commissions
off selling flowers.
I just started weddings
three months ago.
Yesterday,
we did $100,000 in sales,
and $25,000 of it
was weddings.
‐Wow.
‐Ooh.
What caused that?
Um...
We have a big problem at my shop
with production,
and so we purposefully hold
our marketing department back.
But yesterday, I said,
"Throw $4,000 at the ad,
and I want to see
what it does."
You're smart.
You were coming up here
and you wanted to brag.
Yeah.
John: Oh, my God.
Okay, so you spent $4,000
yesterday?
Yeah.
I love her.
And what was a typical day,
prior to yesterday, in sales?
A typical day is anywhere
from $6,000 to $13,000.
Okay, so you created
another $90,000 in sales.
Right.
You're killing it.
[ Chuckles ]
How much of your own money
is in this?
Like $700.
Oh, my God.
But I have a business partner
who helped me.
I was living in a one‐bedroom
apartment, about to be homeless,
and I was on the news because I
was trying out for "Shark Tank"
for my first time...
[ Laughs ]
... and [laughs] they, like,
did a whole news story on it.
And this guy saw me on TV,
and he called me up and he said,
"I want to invest.
What do you need?"
Okay.
And I'm like,
"I need my rent to be paid
and I need groceries."
How much did you sell to him,
and for how much?
He only put in $3,000 up front
for inventory,
and then he paid my rent
every month for a year.
Meagan, how much eq‐‐
He got 25%.
‐So, you gave him 25%.
‐So, hang on. He got 25%...
Mm‐hmm.
... for $3,000
and paying your rent
for a year.
Unbelievable.
O'Leary: Have you taken on
any other investors?
Bowman: Um, I tried out
for "Shark Tank," got denied.
And the business was booming
at this point.
Like, I was ‐‐ I could not
keep inventory in,
so I needed
another investment,
so we found
a local investment firm
that gave us $30,000.
For how much?
Two guys,
so they each took 25%.
So 50%.
Wow. Ouch.
Mm‐hmm.
That leaves 25 ‐‐
so you own 25%.
So, in total,
you sold 75% of your business
for roughly $35,000.
It was hard times, yes.
Wow.
That was
a year and a half ago.
Meagan, one of the reasons
you start a business
is to retain equity.
Right.
And you want to see it grow,
and that's your payback.
I'd give you $400,000.
I would never do it for 10%.
Let's say
I did it for 30%.
Who is going to give me
that stock?
'Cause you're gonna end up
working for me as an employee.
My secretary is gonna own
more stock than you do.
That's ridiculous.
You're ‐‐ you're
getting wiped out.
♪♪
Narrator:
All six Sharks are still in.
While everyone is impressed
with Meagan's big sales
in her faux‐flower delivery
business, Eco Flower,
they're concerned that
she already gave away
75% of her company
to other investors,
only a year and a half
into her business.
I'd give you $400,000.
I would never do it for 10%.
Let's say
I did it for 30%.
Who is going to give me
that stock?
'Cause you're gonna end up
working for me as an employee.
You're getting wiped out.
You sold too much.
Where will the stock
come from?
It'll come
from equal shares.
We have a max that we're
willing to go up to...
[ Sighs ]
... so we can't ‐‐ I mean ‐‐
and my investors are tech guys.
This is not their area.
I want to get them out
at some point,
and so, I mean,
later down the road ‐‐
So you want to use my money
to buy them out?
I don't know who's ‐‐
Which would be smart.
I feel like you guys
would have the contracts...
Now you're talking.
...that can
make that happen.
I feel like that equity
could be used differently,
with people that know
my industry better.
So ‐‐ and they're
open to it.
Well, Meagan, you know,
you've heard the saying,
"It's better to own 10%
of a billion‐dollar company
than a 100% of a ‐‐ "
I know.
That's why I'm here.
Well, the challenge is,
it's very hard to build
a billion‐dollar business.
And when you're starting out
in a small business,
you should try to retain
as much equity as you can
for as long as you can.
But you have
25% ownership.
You don't
control the business,
you don't have the final say
in the business.
Who am I gonna get
into business with?
They're wonderful people.
They really are.
You got to hang on
to the equity.
So, I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
Meagan, I spend
more money on flowers than ‐‐
I'm embarrassed to admit ‐‐
than most people spend
on groceries.
Right.
I just love flowers.
I don't get these.
I see these
all over Manhattan ‐‐
in bathrooms usually.
I don't even understand
why people buy them, honestly.
No!
I don't get it.
I have to love
what I invest in.
Right.
Sorry, I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
Look at you.
I mean, amazing.
Amazing.
You deserve
so much credit.
But this just is not me,
right?
Right.
This is not
my area of expertise.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I just see these
so readily available
out there, everywhere.
I don't think
there is competition.
But you're doing
a great job yourself.
Right. There's not
competition, though.
But I don't ‐‐
We don't have it.
I'm first and best.
I just don't see it as
the right investment for me.
So I'm sorry, I'm out.
Thank you.
It makes it virtually impossible
to invest in you
without diluting you
to a place
where you are basically
an employee.
I'm still doing
a really great job.
There's nobody doing
what I'm doing.
Sorry, Meagan,
it's not investable for me.
I'm out.
I'm number one
in this space.
Come on, Daymond.
I'm gonna do $4 million
this year.
Come on.
[ Chuckles ]
I‐I have
the same, exact concerns
that the other guys have,
that, you know,
you started this whole business
to not work for anybody.
Now you're working
for the company.
So, have you talked
to these tech investors,
and they ‐‐
have they confirmed
that they are willing
to sell their shares as well?
They're willing to share
at the right price, for sure.
I need you to be vested
in this business,
so I want to attempt
to buy them out down the road
and give you a bigger piece
of this business.
So, I'm going to offer you
$400,000 for 25%.
[ Exhales sharply ]
Wow.
That wipes you out.
You'll have no equity.
No, that's not ‐‐
no, it doesn't.
What is it you like
about the business?
No, it ‐‐ it dilutes everybody
about 6%.
Would you do 20%?
That makes us all five, equal.
5%, 5%, 5%, 5% is coming
from all four of your partners,
to make me
a fifth partner?
Yes.
[ Grunts ]
Please.
You got a deal.
Okay, thank you!
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God.
Thank you so much!
Thank you.
Oh, my God!
You're gonna stay
in the business, right?
You promise me?
Yes!
[ Laughs ]
Thank you!
I'm glad you got a deal, too!
It made me 140 bucks.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Oh, my gosh.
I would've gotten that back.
[ Laughs ]
I started this business
watching "Shark Tank."
And to actually be here
and get a deal is incredible.
And I'm not trying
to become a billionaire.
I'm trying to create jobs,
and I'm trying to feed my family
and not struggle again.
And I think I can still do that
with 20%.
Daymond,
I didn't get that deal.
Cash flow.
Cash, cash, cash.
It's ‐‐ it's ‐‐ it's clear
cash flow.
This stuff
is a commodity.
We put this stuff on cards.
We buy it for pennies.
Yeah, exactly, and I'm gonna be
the one to sell it to you.
Here, Daymond.
It's only $399,999 now.
Thank you,
I'll take that.
[ Chuckles ]
Narrator: In season four,
mother‐and‐daughter team
Tracey Noonan and Dani Vilagie
made a deal with Kevin O'Leary
for their cupcakes in a jar.
I want a dollar
from every jar.
Oh.
We'd like to come back to you
with 40 cents a jar.
45 cents,
you have a deal.
Come to mama.
Narrator: Three years later,
let's see how they're doing now.
Vilagie: Today is a big day
for Wicked Good Cupcakes.
Noonan: We're about to sell
our millionth cupcake jar
at our new location
in Faneuil Hall.
Dani, Tracey,
guess who's in town.
‐Hey!
I'm here to help them sell
'cause I want to be here when
we sell that one millionth jar.
I want to sell it.
This is
my favorite flavor.
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had $150,000 in sales.
Since airing, we've now done
over $10 million in sales.
You've just bought the millionth
jar of Wicked Good Cupcakes.
[ Clapping ]
Good job!
When we accepted
the royalty deal with Kevin,
we caught a lot of flack
over that.
In reality, we've retained
all of our equity.
We've grown
by leaps and bounds.
It was the best deal
we could have made.
Four years ago,
Dani and I were baking
out of our home kitchen.
Vilagie: Now we're
selling thousands of jars
from our new
21,000‐square‐foot facility.
We now have 32 employees
and huge partnerships
with multi‐billion‐dollar
companies, like Cinnabon.
Our next big step
is franchising cupcake trucks.
We'll be able
to have physical locations
all across the country.
I'm so proud of you guys.
Thanks to "Shark Tank,"
I've watched Dani grow
from a young person
trying to find herself
to a woman who runs
30‐plus employees,
and it's made me so proud
and so grateful.
My biggest hope
is that our story
inspires other women
to start a business
and to follow a dream.
Together: One million jars!
Man: All right, we're gonna
get started, everybody.
‐Ooh, she's alive.
‐Who's alive?
That ‐‐ they all are!
They're alive!
Cuban: They're alive!
They're cute.
3, 2, 1!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a fashionable business
designed
for the social‐media generation.
Hi, I'm Hilary.
I'm originally
from Pittsburgh, P. A.
And I'm the founder and CEO
of the Style Club.
I'm seeking $500,000
for 20% of my company.
The Style Club
is the first
multi‐platform, young
shopping network.
With all the media
that's accessible,
and mobile shopping
at its all‐time high,
the shopping behavior of the
younger consumer has changed.
It's all about the experience.
Let me show you
how the Style Club works today.
You can go onto our website
and see some
of our super‐hot music videos
featuring
our style influencers.
[ Electronic dance music plays ]
[ Music fades ]
So, our customers
can shop everything
directly on our website.
They can also shop
in our major retail stores.
Or they can shop it
on our app.
Users can go onto our app,
and they can shop it all
right there
with just one click of a button.
It's that easy.
So, which one
of you Sharks
wants to help make the world
more stylish again,
and join the club?
You're in major retail.
Yes.
We're in Urban Outfitters.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I know you guys are looking
at all this stuff,
thinking,
"I want one of those."
I got something for you.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Okay. [ Chuckles ]
[ Chuckling ]
Hey.
Greiner: Yay.
Thank you.
Here you go, Lori.
Do I get black?
Here's your card.
‐I get red?
‐You get red.
Thank you very much,
Hilary.
You're welcome.
Here, I'll help you
put it on, Lori.
Thank you.
Cuban: Thanks.
Appreciate it.
Herjavec:
It says "Boss Babe."
Oh, my God,
you look so cute!
Corcoran: Yeah.
What does
this jacket retail?
"Love Club."
That retails for $60.
So, how did you
start the business?
I originally started
by creating video content.
How long ago was that?
About a year ago.
Oh, you've only had
all of this for a year?
Yes.
What's
in Urban Outfitters?
Our Babe collection.
And then Love Club
will be going in next.
How many Urban Outfitters
are you in?
All of them.
How did you get that done
in one year flat?
Herjavec: Yeah.
They came to us because we have
a very strong social following.
And we work with
all these major influencers.
What type of influencers?
Bloggers, celebrities.
We've reached
over 200,000 followers,
but our influencers
have over 50 million.
How do the sales
break down, Hilary?
What are
the total sales?
And then, show me
the biggest items.
So, the total sales
that we've had to date
is around $400,000.
That's around 40,000 units
thus far.
How much of that is in retail,
how much is online?
All of it, right now,
mostly is in retail.
So, how long
has that been?
It's been
three, four months.
That's much better
than $400,000 a year.
But those are ‐‐
those are just stock ‐‐
We're thinking
$400,000 a year.
It's has been $400,000
in three, four months, correct?
‐Yeah.
‐Okay.
Only at that one chain ‐‐
Urban Outfitters?
Right now,
'cause we gave them exclusivity.
And that's why
we're really here...
Oh.
... so that I can,
you know ‐‐
Exclusivity?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
No other retailer
can carry this.
...if you're getting
$400,000 in...
So, Hilary ‐‐
But it's also continuing.
So, we have POs all the way up
to summer 2017.
And so, Hilary,
out of all these items,
are there one or two that are
the biggest sellers?
Yes.
So, our Babe hat.
‐Which one?
‐This right here.
Our Babe hat.
This is our number‐one seller.
Of the $400,000,
how much of that
is in the Babe hat?
Probably around $300,000.
‐Wow!
$300,000 in sales
on that hat alone?
Yes. Yes.
‐Why is that?
‐So, what's interesting ‐‐
O'Leary: Let me see that hat.
Bring that hat over here.
What's interesting ‐‐
That's a $400,000 hat!
Greiner: There's a lot of hats
that look like that,
so why is that
your number‐one seller?
I'm always watching
what's happening online,
or what girls are wearing
and sharing.
I thought "babe" was insulting
to a young woman today.
No, it's empowering.
"You're a babe."
Greiner: Well,
I mean, she's a babe.
"I feel good."
You know why?
Nobody ever calls you that
anymore, Barbara.
Corcoran: Nobody ever
calls me "babe."
It's a good thing.
Now, did they buy
all those hats
from Urban Outfitters,
or did you sell direct?
Well, we ‐‐ we sold it all
to Urban Outfitters
'cause we had to give them
an exclusive.
Got it.
So you can't even
sell this hat online.
No, you cannot, right now.
Nothing's
selling online.
Everything's going through
Urban Outfitters, correct?
Mm‐hmm.
So, there's a concept
in investing
called "diversification."
That's how you
protect your heinie
when poo‐poo happens.
No, listen!
No, Kevin, you're so wrong!
You are so wrong, Kevin!
Excuse me, Mark,
let me finish my thought.
I'm gonna help you
a lot.
You're all‐in
to one channel.
That ‐‐ that's
your big bet.
You've got a big bet
with Urban Outfitters.
It's too risky.
I'm out.
Incredibly
impressive sales
in a very, very short
amount of time.
What's the bigger plan?
Are you gonna sell online?
Are you gonna go
to other retailers?
The bigger plan
is to really build out
our direct‐to‐consumer.
We really want
to build out that app,
where it's
that video‐shopping app,
making it extremely simple
for people to ‐‐ to watch
and shop all in one place.
You're asking for $500,000
on a baby, baby business.
It's way too much money
for me to have confidence
to give you
that kind of dough.
It just doesn't
make any sense.
There's no room for a partner
in this deal right now,
so I'm out.
Well, we're on track
for $1.2 million this year.
Listen, I have a big dream,
to make this happen,
and I know that if we build out
this online channel,
this direct‐to‐consumer,
because these customers are,
you know, very attached to me,
we can make this happen.
Greiner:
You have a major retailer ‐‐
very cool,
very popular retailer ‐‐
and you're in.
And they've already given you
big purchase orders,
and you've already proven
you're a success.
I think you should try
to just keep making things
and funneling it to them.
Have them
keep expanding you.
I don't see this
as an investment for me
right now,
because my ‐‐ I have
a completely different thought
on ‐‐ on the way
that you should go.
So, I'm out,
but I'd be a customer.
You're cool ‐‐
great way to start a business.
But you have to change
your entire strategy,
and that's what
you need the money for.
For $500,000,
I want a little more proof.
I just wish
there was more data.
To me,
you're a pure start‐up,
looking for
half‐a‐million dollars.
I can't see it.
I'm out, Hilary.
O'Leary: There's good news
for you, Hilary.
You're here on a unique day
in "Shark Tank" history.
There are six Sharks.
You still have 33 1/3% chance.
[ Chuckles ]
Two Sharks
are still looking at you
to actually get a deal.
And those two
are down there.
John: I was inspired by
a company called Cross Colours
that came out.
They went to $100 million,
but they were mainly in one
chain called Merry‐Go‐Round.
And when Merry‐Go‐Round
went bankrupt,
in one year,
they were gone.
But I have
an offer for you.
I like what you're doing,
so I'll give you the $500,000,
and I will ‐‐ I'll ask
for 33 1/3%.
Okay.
All right.
Well, that's an offer.
‐She's halfway there.
‐Okay. Thank you.
Greiner: Mark?
Cuban: So,
I've had experience here
with the Red Dress Boutique,
right?
And they came in
doing the same thing ‐‐
selling on social media,
don't buy it until
it's already sold,
and their biggest challenge
was online.
We had some challenges 'cause
they were growing so quickly,
but we've
gotten through them,
and now they'll do
$14 million‐plus this year.
But here's my offer.
Okay.
I don't want to team
with anybody, right?
What I gather ‐‐
You need expertise and tech.
But, more importantly,
right now,
you need financing
for inventory.
Yes.
So I'm gonna structure it
so that it's $500,000
as a line of credit.
Okay.
So ‐‐ but I'll
discount the rate,
so it's at 8% as opposed
to the normal factoring,
which can be
10%, 12%, or more, okay,
for 22%.
Daymond, I really appreciate
your offer,
but, Mark, you have a deal.
Done!
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Congratulations.
Thank you.
‐Yeah.
‐Ah!
Black and yellow.
Yes, ma'am.
Nice meeting you, Hilary.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
You know, you're a great
designer. Keep designing.
Thank you.
We're gonna kill it.
All right, are we ‐‐
Are you coming with me, or...?
What are we doing?
Okay. [ Laughs ]
No, you're gonna stay there
in that position
for the next four hours.
[ Voice breaking ]
Mom.
Woman: Yeah?
I got a deal from Mark.
Yes.
Uh‐huh.
[ Sniffles, chuckles ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
are entrepreneurs
who believe they have a safer
version of a favorite food.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Bryan.
And I'm Sean.
And we're seeking
$600,000
for a 3% stake
in Safe Catch.
Oh, God.
[ Chuckles ]
Safe Catch is going
to make tuna great again.
Now, I know
you Sharks love tuna.
[ Cuban chuckles ]
But the average person,
over the last 10 years,
is eating 30% less tuna.
And the reason
is mercury.
Two tuna can very in mercury
levels by over 50 times.
Wittenberg:
The great news, Sharks,
is that there's still plenty
of pure tuna in the sea.
The problem is,
there's never been a way
to test each fish
for mercury.
So we developed
a technology
to test each fish
for its mercury level
so that everyone can
feel great about tuna again.
This is our high‐speed
mercury analyzer.
We have a piece
of ahi tuna over here.
We'll test each tuna
one by one
for its mercury
concentration.
And here's how we do it.
We take a modified
biopsy needle ‐‐
a sample tool ‐‐
looks just like this.
It takes a tissue sample
about the size
of a grain of rice.
You select
the fish species.
You drop this bad boy
in there like that.
And the machine
does the rest.
Now, the reason we had
to invent our own technology
is because the existing methods
are a non‐starter.
It costs 100 bucks
per test,
takes a week
to get results back,
requires a lab,
and a ton of logistical hurdles.
With this technology,
we can integrate it directly
into the seafood‐supply chain
and test in real time
for pennies on the dollar.
These machines can perform
over 1,000 tests per day.
But we also found
a better way to make tuna
that tastes better,
looks better,
and is better for you.
So we went out and we created
our own brand of seafood,
and we called it
Safe Catch.
Wittenberg: All of our tuna
is hand‐cut and hand‐packed.
And we put
a sushi‐grade tuna steak
directly into our BPA‐free can,
we seal it,
and then we cook that fish
in its natural fats and oil.
Mmm.
This is great.
Yeah. Your business is not just
about the mercury testing,
it's about a whole‐new way
that you package tuna.
That's right.
It's both.
So you're just trying to be
the healthiest tuna available?
It's the healthiest tuna
on the planet.
That's our goal.
That's exactly right.
I'm very conscious
of mercury in seafood.
I'm one of those people, too,
that really stopped buying it.
I don't eat it very often
for that r‐‐
Because of the mercury?
Because of the mercury.
Because mercury builds up
in your body.
That's right.
Are you accepting any mercury
at all in the fish, or...?
Yeah, so,
the limit in that fish
has a limit
of . 1 parts per million,
which is 10 times stricter
than the FDA.
What are your costs?
So, right now,
that can costs us $1.20 to make,
we sell it for 2 bucks,
and it retails
between $3.00 to $4.00.
We're right now
less expensive
than the other premium brands
on the market,
but we're more expensive
than the conventional brands.
There's been over $12 million
that has been invested
in developing
this technology.
You guys have invested
$12 million?
Let me give you
some history.
I started this
about 12, 13 years ago.
Corcoran: Wow.
I grew up on fish,
my family grew up on fish,
and we said, you know,
we were some smart people.
Let's ‐‐ "We can try
to chase this down
and solve this problem."
So we took this technology
and we invented it.
And being super‐green
and naive,
we said, "Hey, we're just
gonna take it to the market,
and they're just gonna adopt,"
right?
But we kept getting blocked
by those in
the seafood‐supply chain.
And we probably chased
that business strategy
longer than
we should have.
How long?
About 10 years.
‐Ooh.
‐Wow, 10 years.
You had this out
10 years ago?
So, just keep on going.
Keep on going, keep on going.
Greiner: Yeah.
So what happened?
So, we had
about 100 investors
that came into
that last co‐‐
Sean, how much money
did you raise in total
over the entire
period of time?
To date,
we've raised 14 million bucks.
‐Wow.
‐14 million.
What did all that money
go to?
It took four PhD physicists,
we had three engineering labs ‐‐
Boches: So, what happened is,
the investors got tired,
the company
ran out of money,
they couldn't get
into retailers.
I came in with Sean,
and we bought the company out.
What did you buy it for?
Less than $1 million.
Okay.
The $14 million
got wiped out?
‐So they're gone?
‐Yes, they're gone.
Gone.
Was there any other capital
raised after that?
Yes.
I put in over $900,000...
That's all in.
... and the company
has about another 900K
in debt.
What are the sales?
We launched one year ago
in stores.
We're now
in 2,100 stores.
2,100 stores.
The first 12 months
of sales,
we did $1.25 million.
Good for you.
Right now, we're burning about
$70,000 in cash a month.
But you have to understand
that we're a technol‐‐
So you're losing money.
We're losing money.
How much will you lose
this year?
To date,
we've lost $530,000.
Cuban: Look, you guys
just made the comment ‐‐
You're
a technology company.
That's right.
So let's
talk about that.
Right.
So, this is
your proof of concept...
Yep.
... that you can do.
What's next?
Well, first of all,
the canned‐tuna segment
is a $4 billion segment
here in America.
I don't care about that.
I want to hear about
your technology.
What's next?
You've seen
a 30% per capita decline
since the introduction ‐‐
I don't care.
I don't care at all.
Corcoran:
You've covered that.
I just want you to know
there's $4 billion market.
Don't care at all.
I will get you into that ‐‐
what's next ‐‐
I just want to touch
one thing on the ca‐‐
You guys got to learn to listen
more you sell.
O'Leary:
Here's the issue, okay?
Yeah.
You've burned
through $14 million
of some
shareholder's money.
That's a fact.
Trying to build this
as a model for the industry
that everybody would use,
they elected not to.
So I would never
get my $600,000 back
until you actually end up
with about 20% share
of this declining sector.
And...I'm out.
‐Okay.
That's
en‐entirely misplaced.
Right now,
the food‐tech space
is one
of the hottest spaces.
But here's the challenge
with ‐‐ with your pitch ‐‐
You're not a tech play,
so you're coming in
with a food product
asking for
a tech valuation.
I don't think the market's
gonna adopt your technology.
I'm out.
Corcoran: This is
the way I see it ‐‐
you've had a loss of ‐‐
what did you say? ‐‐
$70,000 a month
after $14 million
going into this business.
Think about that.
Does that sound like
a sexy proposal?
"Come with me...
[ Laughs ]
... we've lost
$14 million,
but we're only
losing $70,000 a month."
I am so out on this.
Okay.
‐Thank you.
Thank you for what you're doing,
to try to save our families.
I mean,
I ‐‐ I eat a lot of fish,
so I'm filled with mercury,
but I burn it off
with the vodka.
So, um...
[ Laughter ]
Does vodka help get rid
of the mercury?
It burns it right off.
You have about $2.5 million
total into the company,
you're burning $70,000
a month,
but you're offering us
the valuation
as if the full $14 million
was still in.
And I really don't
understand that.
I'm out.
In this space,
a $40 million‐revenue company
is selling
for $200 million.
Healthier foods right now
are a huge trend.
And we are
a pure technology company
that's gone and shifted
to food.
What about
the test outcome?
No, you're out,
so I'm gonna listen to Mark.
Yeah, I know, but ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
‐He's a beast.
‐Good for you.
I just want to know
what happened to the test.
Is it out?
Yeah.
So, right now, this machine,
right now, performed the test.
Boches:
So, you got the red screen,
so that fish did not pass.
This is a sushi‐grade tuna loin,
highest quality,
but it didn't pass
our test.
We wouldn't have accepted
that fish.
Okay, so guys,
your valuation is crazy.
You're burning through
a boatload of cash.
We're building the brand
right now. But if our ‐‐
But then it's a question
of scale,
to get to your valuation.
I mean, let's talk.
I mean,
the yogurt company
that grew in just yogurt
to $1 billion.
‐That's not ‐‐
‐Don't do that.
Don't go there.
The jerky company
that just sold
for $270 million.
You have to grow 37 times
to get
to your $40 million in sales
from your $1.25 million
over the last two months.
We'll be at $8 million
next year.
I'm out.
Okay.
Five Sharks are out,
but you're still alive 'cause
there's six Sharks up here.
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Lori is liking what you're
saying ‐‐ you can tell.
No, I like what you're doing.
I think it's important.
This is a big problem,
and you have a big idea.
But the strategy
that I see
is I think you have to go
to the governmental bodies
and have them make this
a requirement,
and that's not your path
right now.
I'll be a customer,
and I appreciate
what you're doing,
but I'm out.
Okay.
Boches: Thank you.
Thank you so much
for all your time.
Good luck, guys.
We appreciate you guys.
Good luck.
Have a good
rest of your day.
♪♪
Boches: It went
completely opposite
from what we expected.
We never really
got our vision across,
and how big
our market is.
It just ‐‐ I was sh‐‐
pretty much shocked by that.
I was shocked.
Mark,
why don't we find out
if you have any mercury
in you?
Bend over.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a platform to help you
explore your passions.
I'm calling [bleep]
[ Scattered chuckles ]
I'm calling
every single one of you out.
I'm calling myself out.
All this talk about dreams
and drive and destiny,
countless conversations
about what we love,
inspirational quotes
and motivational mantras.
We're all talk.
And I've had enough.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Kash Shaikh.
I'm the founder
of #besomebody,
and we're seeking $1 million
for 10% of our company.
We built the world's first
experience marketplace
with the vision to pioneer
experiential learning.
On our platform,
you can learn anything
that you're passionate about,
by booking experiences
with talented people around you.
You book them online,
and you meet up in person
for a hands‐on
learning experience.
And the hosts
of our experiences ‐‐
who we call "Passionaries" ‐‐
get to make money
doing what they love.
So, Robert, if you wanted
to add ninja skills
to your already‐sexy repertoire
of scuba diving and car racing,
you could book
an experience
with ninja warrior
Travis Brewer.
[ Electronic music playing ]
Whoa!
‐Cool.
‐[ Laughs ]
Herjavec: Don't faaall!
Go, Travis!
‐Oh, wow.
‐Yeah!
Yeah.
Whoa.
[ All cheer ]
Shaikh:
Or, Daymond, Kevin, ladies...
Very cool.
...if you guys wanted
to ignite
your dormant passion
for dance,
which I know y'all have, you
could book a group experience,
and you can learn anything
from ballet to ballroom
to Bollywood!
[ Electronic Indian music
playing ]
[ Dancers cheering ]
Shaikh: Yeah!
Whoo!
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Wow.
All right.
[ Cuban chuckles ]
Yeah!
‐Whoo!
Shaikh: And, Mark,
you could book
a soccer experience.
You can learn
from the best ‐‐
two‐time World Cup champion,
two‐time Olympic gold medalist
Kristine Lilly.
Wow.
Cuban: Whoo!
What's up, Kristine?
What's up, my man?
How are you you?
Good.
Hello, Sharks.
I'm here today
as a #besomebody Passionary
and someone who truly
loves this company
and everything
it stands for.
And they will host
all our soccer experiences
exclusively
on their platform.
Sharks, we really believe
we have the right mission,
the right movement,
and the right model.
And we would love
for all of you to join us
on this world‐changing
journey.
Thank you so much to our amazing
Passionaries and #besomebody.
‐Thank you!
‐Thanks, guys!
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Great.
Tell us a little bit
about your background.
So, back in 2009,
I was seven years into my role
at Procter & Gamble,
the largest consumer‐products
company in the world.
I was leading social marketing
for a lot of our bigger brands,
like Tide and Old Spice.
And I just turned 30,
I was going through a breakup,
and I was trying to figure out
what my purpose was in life.
And that's when I first
started to realize is,
sooner you start to focus
your mind and your heart
and your spirit and your soul
on your passions,
the universe starts to open up
doors and unlock windows
you never thought possible.
And I started to learn
the power of this word,
because it's intuitive and
instantly personal to people.
When people around the world
hear "be somebody,"
it becomes about you
and what you love.
It becomes about
your personal passion,
whether it's photography,
or car racing, or fashion.
That's what's powerful
about it.
And as soon as I started
to really see
that there was
something there,
I got a chance to leave P&G
and go lead social marketing
at GoPro,
working for somebody
you know well ‐‐ Nick Woodman.
Kash, you're doing
a lot of talking...
Right.
... and you're not
getting anywhere right now.
Right.
What's the end product?
What am I buying?
Let me show you guys.
So, we built an iOS app.
This is my profile.
You see all your profiles
right here.
Okay.
This is my profile page.
If you hit that little plus,
it opens up all my passions.
You can add as many as you want.
You can create them.
And then our algorithm
takes everything
you're passionate about
then shows you experiences
around you, in your local area.
It's an experience
marketplace.
Think about Airbnb,
when you're booking houses.
Here, you can book
an experience.
And then you can
book it on ‐‐
For that individual training,
what's a typical fee?
Yeah, great question.
We take 20%
of every experience
that's booked
on our platform.
On average,
$40 an experience.
You actually have to aggregate
a whole bunch of Passionaries.
Exactly.
By the way,
I love your name ‐‐ Kash.
Thank you.
[ Chuckles ]
But, unfortunately,
I've learned
that happiness
can't buy money.
So,
I've got to understand
how fast you can
scale this thing...
Right.
Great question.
... so I can make "cash."
Right.
So, what we have ‐‐
We have a global movement
that reaches
5 million people.
That means
5 million people a month
are either dropping
this #besomebody hashtag...
If you guys search it
right now ‐‐
like, get out your phones,
search any social ‐‐
That doesn't mean
it's attributable.
But is that
of your company,
or just in general
"be somebody," because ‐‐
I was the first person
in history
to trademark a hash,
back in 2011.
But even
if you trademark it,
you just put in a hashtag
and "be," it'll pop up,
and someone
could still click on it.
So it doesn't mean
it's necessarily related to ‐‐
Right, but we own every asset
with #besomebody.
That's fine.
It's great for branding.
So, it's kind of like GoPro ‐‐
like, we branded the fisheye.
We're just trying to see
what connects to revenue.
Right, right.
Kash, I'm a little confused
what the platform is.
Is the idea,
we just get together
and do an activity we like,
like white‐water rafting,
or is it
a training platform
where I go to an expert
white‐water‐rafting person?
Great question. I wanted to get
back to the scale question.
I think that's important.
The number‐one way
we found to scale
is through
strategic partnerships.
You guys just heard
from Kristine Lilly, so ‐‐
How do you protect
yourself against ‐‐
Barbara and I,
we go white‐water rafting,
a big, jagged rock
comes up...
I would like that, actually.
... somebody pushes her
off the boat,
she cracks her head
to the white meat...
Right.
Before her husband gets
a brand‐new, sexy wife,
... he sues somebody.
Right, right.
How do you protect yourself
against lawsuits like that?
Right now,
we haven't had that problem.
We know we're gonna have
to figure that out ‐‐
What would be the answer
if you had that problem?
I think that's the reason
we're raising capital ‐‐
you know,
because we need some ‐‐
Oh, so we could lose it
in a lawsuit?
To insure yourself,
or do you have a disclaimer?
‐Well, no, are you insured?
‐I mean, what happens?
So, wait. How long have you
been offering experiences?
12 months in Austin, Texas,
in 2015.
So 12 months just as a beta,
you said?
Yeah.
‐So what are your sales?
‐Are you open to everybody yet?
Yeah, at the end of 2015,
we decided we're gonna ‐‐
our focus is scale ‐‐
so the first six months
of 2016,
we've been
closing partnerships.
80,000 artists
across the country, PPA ‐‐
So how many, um, experiences
did you book last month?
Probably about $2,000.
Okay.
So, again, we have a f‐‐ we're
building a global marketplace.
Wow, that's low.
Right, it's low.
John: Your answer to
the potential litigation was,
you're raising capital.
Is that to get
a big insurance policy?
I mean, how are you
going to protect yourself?
Yeah, I mean,
every Passionary
that hosts a fitness
or outdoor experience
has to have liability insurance
on their own.
It's part of our terms.
Okay, so ‐‐
And with the strategic
partnerships, when we scale,
the reason why
they're partnering with us ‐‐
there's three reasons.
One, because they believe
in the mission.
You heard Kristine Lilly.
Two, because they have
a shared goal of education.
But you don't have
any traffic yet.
Why would she give you
exclusivity
when you have nobody
on this thing?
Because you probably had
to qualify the exclusivity
to an app
or something specific,
as opposed to all bookings,
right?
We ‐‐ no, all bookings.
100% of bookings.
So all their ‐‐
100% of their revenue
is dependant on you.
Right.
But listen to me,
I've closed ‐‐
Did you guarantee her
any minimums?
No, we didn't.
We didn't.
Corcoran:
Kash, you have ‐‐
But you got
to understand ‐‐
Kash.
Time out.
Kash!
Yoo‐hoo!
Yoo‐hoo.
She's gonna starve!
She's begging for ‐‐
No, Mark ‐‐ Mark, no,
because, Mark, she ‐‐
He's running out
of cash.
Kash!
One sec. One second,
just to finish with Mark.
No, focus here a second,
Kash.
Mark, we become payment platform
and tool for them.
But I think that, guys,
what's the most important
part about this
is people believe
in what we stand for.
I'm gonna show you guys
one thing, real quick.
Oh, my God.
'Cause I think ‐‐
I think it's important.
I‐I used to carry this around
back in 2011.
A little 8x11 card
that I made myself...
Kash, you're killing us.
... when I was going
around the world
to try to inspire people.
Kash, Kash,
you're killing us.
Did you bring
a collection plate?
Narrator:
All six Sharks are still in,
but Mark has an issue with Kash
selling the passion
more than the merits
of his business, #besomebody,
a booking platform
for experiences.
Cuban:
Kash, rule number one ‐‐
the longer the back story,
the worse the deal.
Well, let me tell you
about our business.
Rule number two ‐‐
more preaching always equals
less money for the investor.
For those two reasons,
I'm out.
Right.
I find you
enormously abrasive.
You drive me nuts.
I feel as though you don't have
the capacity to listen.
Could you imagine
what kind of a partner
you would make for me?
I'm out.
Right.
Herjavec:
Kash, here's the beauty
of a social platform,
here's the beauty
of a movement ‐‐
a movement, by nature,
is viral.
Right.
You're not getting
that growth.
No, it's working in Austin.
‐Maybe it's not working.
‐It's working.
We don't
have Passionaries yet
because we haven't ‐‐ we haven't
scaled our marketplace.
You know, my BS ‐‐ I'm not
calling you out on this...
Right, right.
...I'm just saying, my sense
for that always goes up.
I don't understand
the business.
Right.
I mean, I'm out.
Greiner:
I'm gonna jump in.
So, there's so many
apps out there.
It seems to me like
this is just not gonna be one
that's gonna make it.
I'm out.
Kash, how much ‐‐ how much
of your own money
do you have in this?
$200,000.
‐Wow.
‐$200,000. Are you ‐‐
We are pioneering
experiential learning.
No, you're not.
Education is
a $4.1 trillion industry!
Online learning is going
three times as fast!
Preach, preach, preach,
preach, preach, preach.
But, Mark, it's important.
It's important, Mark.
Preach, preach, preach.
I still never got over
how you're going
to protect yourself
against liabilities.
I just think you're gonna have
a lot of people
teaching
dangerous things,
and one lawsuit can kill
the entire company.
I'm out.
Let's leave all the passion
and all the s‐‐
The Kumbaya?
Kumbay‐‐ leave it aside
for a second.
In the end, "Shark Tank"
is about making money.
We built a brand, Kevin.
I'm gonna put ‐‐
You know what's gonna
screw you up, Kash?
The fact that you're believing
your own nonsense.
These are real ‐‐
this is real data.
These are real numbers.
Sometimes,
you got to do the work.
Just tweeting "be somebody"
doesn't get [bleep] done, bro!
You got to do something.
What do you think I've been
doing for three years?!
Talking!
Talking, talking, talking.
No, we haven't.
We built a community
from this.
He's an instructor.
What do you think he does?
We built
a passionate community.
Go online,
just search "be somebody,"
you're gonna get inspired by
all the stories that you hear!
The people that are here,
they're inspired
by the movement...
O'Leary: Kash.
... to have an opportun‐‐
Kash.
[ Scattered chuckles ]
Silence, all right?
We're gonna own the experient‐‐
I'm calling you out.
In eight years of history,
you're one
of the first people
to ever have six shots
at this, okay?
Right, right.
You struck out
on every one.
I appreciate it.
Zero.
I'm out.
See ya, buddy.
Go be somebody, bro.
Greiner: Good luck.
Hey, keep ‐‐ keep out ‐‐
watching out for us,
you guys will see it.
We will.
We sure will.
Everybody's gonna say
that they, you know,
heard about this one day
and that they wish that
they were a part of it.
So, you know,
the Sharks can keep investing
in, like, sideshow Porta‐Pottis
and things like that.
We're building a platform that's
gonna change the world.